fairness
is a beautiful word it has a certain
radiant symmetry
to it it is challenging to define but we
know it when we see it
we know it when people treat us fairly
we also know it when they do not
and unfairness has a profound impact and
a lasting effect
history literature music they're all
littered with powerful examples of
unfairness whether it's cinderella or
billy budd whether it's watching or
reading accounts of
innocent people charged convicted and
punished unfairness
has or should have a profound impact on
all of us
you know sometimes in life or in sports
the referee or the judge is bad to both
sides like an umpire who just can't
decide what the strike zone is no matter
which team's batting and which team is
pitching but sometimes it seems all the
calls go against us
what happens when the referee calls
fouls against us
but never against the other team what
happens when a different standard is
applied to
us than is applied to others
what happens when someone notices all of
our flaws and all of our faults but
recognizes none of the flaws and faults
present
in the other side i have rarely been the
victim of unfairness in my life
i have not experienced unfairness so
much as i have observed it
but when you do experience unfairness
even in something small
it impacts you it impacts how you view
yourself
it impacts how you view others and it
impacts how you think others view
you fairness is no longer an objective
it has now become a tool we reorder or
restructure what is fair we in essence
redefine the word
we minimize the spirit treatment the end
justifies the means because the means is
no longer even-handed
when you experience unfairness you begin
to no longer
see it as that aspirational virtue we
should all long for
we see it as an illusion a reality song
for some
but not for us we start looking for
makeup calls for things to go our way
even if they're undeserved because
that fairness equilibrium needs to be
restored
long-term systemic unfairness changes
the way we view
and define what is fair
i think we are in desperate need of a
societal referee
a judge that even when we don't always
like him or her
we always respect him or her and that
role is supposed to be played by the
media
but it is not and it has not been for
many years
the american people are smart enough to
see the unfairness paul
after paul after paul reflects this the
media is no longer a referee
the media has become a participant the
american people see democrat governors
like andrew cuomo and gavin newsom
winning awards and being praised for
their handling of the pandemic
while republican governors like ron
desantis and greg abbott
are vilified and if you don't believe me
watch this
you've done an amazing job in california
governor desantis's
decision to keep opening the beaches and
doing things that are
particularly unsafe it is beyond
foolhardy
and perilous for them to pursue such a
course
please welcome his excellency governor
andrew cuomo
thank you for everything you're doing to
keep our state safe
and the public informed people are not
comprehending the magnitude of the
problem because governors like
abbott plowed ahead with reopening the
state even as new cases continue to
increase
i know that you've been portrayed as
some sort of a homecoming
king of this crisis and a headline from
jezebel help i think i'm in love with
andrew cuomo
wow they see tough questions to ask of
republican presidents while president
obama
is asked if he ever gets tired of being
so wonderful
and we learned today president biden
wants to see the questions ahead of time
when is the last time nancy pelosi got a
tough question
from the new york times when is the last
time
adam schiff got a tough question from
politico
or anyone else for that matter there's a
reason the american people believe the
media is biased
because the media is biased that's why
we can survive where the media people
don't like
we cannot survive with a media people do
not trust
when i was in congress there were some
house democrats who treated me and other
republicans with more fundamental
fairness than the d.c media did
and at the top of that list was a
progressive democrat from the state of
hawaii
former member of congress former
presidential candidate
and current american soldier
tulsi gabbard tulsi aloha
aloha my friend it's good to see you
it's good to see you also now i'm gonna
i'm gonna ask you
a tough question i perceive
that you were treated unfairly i
perceived that there were times in your
congressional career and as a
presidential
candidate that there was a different set
of rules applied to you was that my own
bias of liking you
or have you perceived that if you're a
little bit out of the democrat
mainstream maybe they don't treat you
the same
your perception would be accurate sir
i am not the only one who has been
subjected to
this bias that we've seen across the
media and unfortunately
uh i think none of this would come as a
surprise
to the american people who are who are
watching this show right now and it's
led to this distrust
in a media that should be presenting
itself
as true journalists with with unbiased
and neutral information
from which people who are watching can
can draw their own conclusions and
the reason for this is we've got a media
frankly that's driven
by profits in how do we get the highest
ratings
how do we get the most clicks in media
and
especially when you've got newsrooms
that have been moved into the
entertainment
divisions of these massive media
corporations
the news becomes entertainment and and
what is entertaining well drama and
conflict sells so
let's see and i saw this through through
the debates in the presidential campaign
especially but there's so many examples
of
let's see how we can fuel this conflict
culture and and divisiveness
to drive up those ratings to drive up
those profits
without any regard for the detrimental
and destructive divisive consequence
in tearing apart our country and
obviously big tech and social media is
doing the exact
same thing and and this is where um
action needs to be taken
to hold these corporations responsible
for those consequences i think
reinstating the fairness doctrine is a
good first step but it doesn't go nearly
far enough to address the the enormity
of this problem
we the people have to change the social
norms just as we did with big tobacco
that used to promote
cigarettes as something is as happy and
healthy when it was actually destructive
we need to do the same thing with
with these uh for-profit media engines
who are tearing our country apart
and say that this is not acceptable
because
if we don't do that if we just stand by
and let this status quo
continue our country will continue to be
torn apart we will be torn apart as
americans
and the united states of america
will no longer exist
yeah those are really famous people who
said a house divided cannot
stand and exactly you raise you
you raise an issue that i don't know the
answer to i mean which came first
it was there's this insatiable public
desire for discord or where we just fed
a steady
stream of it and we become acclimated i
mean congress was nothing like it is now
when you and i serve together it may not
have been perfect
but we didn't need metal detectors when
you and i work together
it's gotten worse and worse over time
and i think there's a direct correlation
between
those in the media these massive
corporations who are profit driven as
well as big tech who is profit driven
recognizing hey look we can make more
money
when we are throwing fuel on the flames
of this conflict culture this
divisiveness
and stoking these fires that are that
are um
hyping people's emotions and worst fears
uh whether they're based on reality or
not and and this is this is really
what's so dangerous is because
if anybody spends any time on twitter or
or social media
you see how this conflict culture is
everywhere it's inescapable
now it's starting to or maybe it has
been for some time but you're seeing
this translating from online to uh
real life and and that's that's again
where where so much of the danger lies
tulsi i want to ask you one more
question or make one more observation
when you when you called my name in that
debate i was watching the debate
uh and i cringed for you because i knew
that there would be punishment for you
being one of the most well-respected
democrats on my side of the aisle and
telling the truth about the fact that
you had friends
on the other side of the aisle we just
got to get to a better place where you
can be free to be friends with folks
even if you vote differently and there
was
no one better at that than you were
so thank you your service to our country
i can't wait to see you thanks for your
friendship all right
we'll talk again soon